It seems like only yesterday that The Office
— the American take on the BBC's original
workplace comedy — closed its doors.
And while many members of its memorable cast
have moved on to other projects or pursuits,
we can't help but wonder: Whatever happened
to David Denman, the actor who played Pam's
ex-fiancé, Roy Anderson?
We know Roy struck it rich with his own gravel
company, married a restaurant owner, and even
learned how to play piano …
[Playing piano and singing] "She's got a way
about her/I don't know what it is"
… but that all took place in the fantasy
land of Scranton, Pennsylvania.
What did Denman really do after The Office?
Let's take a closer look at what he's been
up to since viewers said goodbye to Dunder
Mifflin.
He bossed around Steve Jobs
Well, he bossed around the Ashton Kutcher
version of Steve Jobs.
"Listen, Steve.
You're good.
You're damn good.
But you're an a--hole."
Denman played the small but important role
of programming pioneer and Pong creator Al
Alcorn in the 2013 biographical drama Jobs.
Though it's not the most memorable part in
the critically panned film, not everyone can
claim that they hurled a profane insult at
the late co-founder and former CEO of Apple.
That's a long way from stacking boxes for
Dunder Mifflin.
But that wasn't Denmen's only 2013 gig.
He also stepped into the shoes of Private
McQuarrie in the post-apocalyptic sci-fi action
flick After Earth — the second movie to
star father-and-son duo Will and Jaden Smith.
"Might wanna go easy on him, Sarge.
That's the Prime Commander's son right there."
The film was widely panned by critics and
viewers alike, and it has gone down as one
of both Smith's and director M. Night Shyamalan's
least memorable projects.
Fortunately for those involved, it didn't
turn out to be quite the career-demolishing
disaster it may have seemed — Shyamalan
rebounded with Split in 2017, while both Smiths
always have plenty of projects in the pipeline.
As for Denman?
After Earth's failure definitely didn't stop
him from landing more roles.
He went to boot camp
"You know, I do have a gun in my cubby, and
I will use it."
In order to prepare for his role as Boon in
the biographical war thriller 13 Hours: The
Secret Soldiers of Benghazi, Denman put himself
through boot camp — but not just to learn
how to shoot guns.
The actor, who starred in the flick alongside
fellow Office alum John Krasinski, wanted
to really get into the mind of elite operatives.
He told Backstage,
"They're of a different ilk.
They do stuff that I don't necessarily understand
and put themselves in harm's way without batting
an eye."
Denman was also surprised to learn about the
positive impact The Office had on the actual
secret soldiers of Benghazi, saying,
"One of these guys came up after a screening
and said, 'We watched The Office like crazy.
It got us through so much.'
[...] I sat there in awe that some guy overseas,
trying to protect our interests, was using
a silly comedy as a survival tool.
My brain had an explosion.
I was really moved by that."
All we wanna know is: How many times did those
badass soldiers force The Office's Jim and
Roy to reenact their on-screen rivalry?
"I'm gonna kill Jim Halpert."
He put a ring on it
Though Denman hasn't spent much time in the
spotlight for his various supporting roles,
his marriage to Swedish-American actress and
former Fear the Walking Dead star Mercedes
Mason has garnered the attention of celebrity-adoring
media.
The couple tied the knot in 2014, and Denman
celebrated their one-year anniversary on Instagram.
It really does look like everyday is getting
better for the two — or should we say three.
Denman and Mason took to Instagram to announce
that they were expecting their first child.
And in January 2018, Mason gave birth to a
baby boy.
As usual, Denman headed over to Instagram
to share the news — and compliment his wife
for being such "a champ."
No stranger to the small screen
Though Denman hasn't really been a leading
man yet, you've definitely seen him on some
of your favorite shows.
He's made supporting appearances on Person
of Interest, Vegas, How to Get Away with Murder,
Two and a Half Men, Impress Me, Mad Men, and
True Detective.
Come to think of it, he's actually been pretty
hard to miss.
He's also been featured as a prominent recurring
cast member in Parenthood and Outcast.
With an ever-growing resumé, expect to keep
seeing Denman pop up on your favorite series
for years to come.
That is, if he isn't busy landing larger roles
on the big screen.
He rubs elbows with the Hollywood elite
In 2017, Denman appeared alongside some big-name
talent in director Steven Soderbergh's heist
comedy Logan Lucky, as car dealer Moody Chapman.
"I love stick!
I'm a big fan of stick!"
The film boasts a cavalcade of household names
including the likes of Channing Tatum, Adam
Driver, Katie Holmes, and Daniel Craig.
Certainly not bad company for Denman — especially
considering how successful the kooky caper
turned out.
Logan Lucky gained critical praise for its
goofball humor and pitch-perfect ensemble
cast, and it stands out as a recent highlight
on Denman's CV.
A bright future in film
We certainly haven't seen the last of Denman,
who's come a long way since playing Roy.
In 2018, the versatile actor starred alongside
Kelly Macdonald in the Marc Turtletaub-directed
movie Puzzle.
The film centers around a suburban mother
who discovers her penchant for puzzles — changing
both her and her family's lives.
It's also an adaptation of the 2010 Argentine
film Rompecabezas, which was nominated for
the Golden Bear at the Berlin International
Film Festival.
For Denman though, it's another step in the
right direction toward an increasingly impressive
filmography.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!